hello
okay we're going to get started
um
first off thank you everyone for coming
to the transcriptomics orientation if
you guys have been to any other
orientations whether that be for the
other training modules or
for the overall informational
session that was last week this will be
a bit of a review for the first about 15
minutes or so
so i do want to start off by thanking
both lsu biomed which is the division of
biotechnical and molecular medicine at
lsu
which comprises a variety of cores that
are available for their own
sub-specialties
as well as lbrn which is the louisiana
biomedical research network they are the
two groups that are funding
the training modules this semester
uh just to address a quick question will
there be any participation certificate
for today's webinar uh no this is just
an orientation information an
informational session um
so there are three training modules that
are being offered this semester today
we're gonna be talking about the
transcriptomics
um first off let me emphasize some of
the things about the training modules
first off they're entirely asynchronous
you can participate them in them at any
of your available schedules
if something doesn't work out for you
you can always come back and watch
recorded lectures you can access the
asynchronous courses online at any time
this is really designed to fit within
our busy schedules as researchers or as
scientists
however you're not going to be left on
your own the goal of this training
module um is to help you through the
process to learn more about
transcriptomics whether that be single
cell or bulk um and so there's a variety
of mentors
that will be available to you
to help you through this process so
you're going to primarily interact with
these mentors through the lectures so if
you participate in the lectures when
they're given live you'll be able to ask
questions directly there however if you
aren't able to do so because of your
schedule there are a variety of other
ways to reach out to these mentors one
of which is online chat so there's
several methods that we'll talk about
later on
about how you can reach out to these
mentors if you run into any issues or
just have a curiosity question and
they'll be able to assist you
additionally if you complete
these training modules you will
receive a certificate of completion and
it's going to be associated with what
institution you're from so if you're
associated directly with lsu you'll
receive a certificate
that is customized to lsu and is going
to be signed by dr gus casoulis if you
are with lbrn you are likely to be
receiving a certificate customized lbrn
signed by the bioinformatics core lead
at lbrn which is dr chris taylor
and if you're out if you're outside
either of those two networks you're
going to receive a certificate of
completion from the omics logic team
themselves
so there's going to be three primary
ways that you're going to participate in
this program
the first one is if you haven't already
done so please go over to
learn.omixlogic.com and register because
the omixlogic portal is your primary way
of accessing the information you will
need to access for this training module
it's how you're going to be enrolled in
the the course
as well as how to access your
asynchronous courses so if you haven't
done it already and you're still
interested in joining make sure you do
that right away
most of you probably already have
so you'll be able to we'll walk through
some of the syllabus stuff on the
mxlogic portal in a little bit
but another platform that you will gain
access to if you've already registered
on mxlogic it should automatically give
you a t bioinfo platform
access as well this platform is designed
for individuals to take omics data
whether that be in whatever form you're
working with it in and work through a
essentially a flow chart or a pipeline
as it's referred to as
to process that data using the different
analysis techniques that you'll learn
about during this training module so you
don't have to go and encode all of that
information yourself the pipeline will
help you do that
additionally you will have some
experience or interaction with code the
coding playground which is essentially
designed as an online
coding environment prepared for you so
you can practice coding without having
to establish a coding playground on your
own computer which can be somewhat
difficult for individuals that aren't
experienced with the process
so those are the three things you're
going to be focusing on and some of the
benefits of this training module
this is going to be an advanced training
module that means there's an expectation
that you fully understand biological and
computational verbiage or at least the
large majority of the verbiage you'll
see you're going to you're expected to
have some statistical experience you
don't have to be a statistician but you
should have the understanding of some of
the basic concepts
you may have some coding experience with
either r or python most likely are for
biologists but not always the case
as well as you should have some
understanding of next generation
sequencing and how it works and if you
don't understand it fully that's okay
because the the training module will go
through that
some of these processes for you
that being said today is the orientation
session for this training module you
should already have access if you've
registered in advance if you don't
please reach out to one of us so that we
can get you enrolled
now what exactly is this training module
focused on
this training module is designed to show
you how to perform transcriptomic data
analysis and data visualization many of
us have already seen how this data is
visualized through papers and other
omics related studies that we've read
this training module is designed to show
you some of the behind the scenes stuff
that happens to get to that point with
your data
you're going to cover a lot of different
topics such as machine learning for
expression data some data analysis
exploratory data analysis
methods as well as here's an example of
multivariate analysis
they'll be discussing some next-gen uh
sequencing processing for gene
expression data and here's some of the
data mining classification information
you'll cover um as well as how to
biologically interpret uh that data
which many of us have probably seen
something similar to pathway analysis or
downstream analysis uh while we go
through our biological related papers
so you're also going to have the
opportunity to complete your own
independent transphobic project during
this training module
so
that if you have your own data you can
actually incorporate it here
if not there is still a variety of
publicly available data that pine bio
has actually provided for this course
for this training module to help you
through it
and like i mentioned you will learn how
to identify analyze and visualize all
the appropriate data for transcriptomic
data
so
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
here this is the finalized syllabus for
the training module you can access this
online as well um if you go to the link
that was just provided
in the chat
and you can go through the the actual
subtopics that are in each lecture if
you're curious
this is some of the things are going to
be covered in this course just to kind
of summarize you're going to have a
variety of asynchronous courses and
tutorials to help you through the
process you'll have access to mentor
support you'll have methods explained to
you how are they performed why are they
performed what is the benefit what are
what are the pros and cons of using that
particular analysis
you're going to have multi-omics ai
guided instructions this is an image
here of the pipeline that i was
discussing on the tbio platform you'll
learn what each one of these particular
subsets
is involved with and why it's performed
how it's performed et cetera
you'll get to analyze gene expression
data
you'll learn some
some of the logic behind data science
which many of our us as biologists may
not be exposed to on a regular basis you
also have some biomedical data exposure
as well as that project that i uh
mentioned to you and then if you choose
to do so you should be able to then take
that project at the end of this training
module and present it
at a conference of your choice and i'll
talk about one of those particular
conferences here in a second
so if you're part of lsu or lbrn there
are some additional resources available
to you that could be beneficial outside
of this training module so
if you're in the network there's a lsu
gene lab which lsu gene lab is a sub
core in the biomed program it's
available to both lsu and lbrn labs and
it provides a variety of both
consultation and experimental services
so if you don't know how to perform
perform a variety of experiments
yourself
thea in the gene lab would be an
excellent person to reach out to to see
if she could perform that for you at an
affordable price some of those process
some of those services i've listed here
which include sequencing and next-gen
sequencing techniques multiplex protein
analysis and more now this is just a
subset if you're curious you can go to
their website uh after the lecture
additionally
if you are associated with the lbrn or
an lbrn associated institution
there's the bioinformatics biostatistics
and computational biology core which is
designed to provide consulting
mentorship and training in the field of
data science and bioinformatics uh
primarily directed to faculty or pis
additionally like i mentioned that
conference and that potential to present
your project there is the annual lbrn
conference
on computational biology and
bioinformatics this is usually held
around april um but it's focused on the
springtime so that's not necessarily a
solid date
just keep a lookout for more information
about that if you're interested
additionally if you would like to
continue your knowledge on
bioinformatics there is a master's
program available at lsu health in new
orleans
so you can look into that if you want to
continue learning about this
if you're a faculty or you're a pi
member and you're interested about
having these programs offered at your
institution you can reach out to ilya
brodsky who is the ceo of pine biotech
at ilia
and he will have more information about
what
programs they offer
if you are interested
so i'm going to stop here for any
questions before i show you guys a
little bit about the omixlogic portal
and hand it off before i hand it off to
the pine biome mentors
uh one question why the need for single
uh
and
or bulk transgenders and not just
transgenics um so ilia will actually get
into that a little bit into his portion
of the discussion which will happen in a
little bit he'll give you more details
about uh the benefits of both and what's
going to be covered in the lecture
um
are there any other non-lsu students
here uh yes there's a variety of non-lsu
students in the chat right now um
this program is totally online
the only issue is uh if you're not lsu
or lbrm associated you're not going to
have this available to you for free
you'll have to fund it yourself
okay so
that being said i'm going to go ahead
and stop sharing my this screen for a
second and i'm going to show you guys a
little bit about
the um
omixlogic portal
okay
so if you guys like i said haven't
already done this please go to omixlogic
uh the omixologic portal
where you'll be able to
or learn.mxlogic.com
basically it'll take you to this screen
here
what you can do if you're interested um
you could register entirely for free
this is not going to be directly linked
to the program when you register this is
just to give you access to the portal so
if you're curious you can hit register
for free
which will take you to a sign in or sign
up
page where if you have an account you
can just sign in but if you don't have
an account you can sign up by clicking
one additional button and i'll show you
here once that loads
so if you haven't made an account you
just have to click on create an account
here and this box will expand and allow
you to enter some information like your
name
the email address and your new password
that you'd like to use because i've
already made an account i'm not going to
do that i'm going to stay here on the
sign in page
i'm gonna go ahead and sign in
it'll take you to a page like this
my recommendation for the quickest way
to access everything that you that you
would be uh involved in is to go to your
profile by clicking on the welcome back
where your email should pop up
and it'll take you to this page
so if you're already in a program and
you're already enrolled in a program
you'll be able to see that program down
here in the badges section so for this
particular program you should see this
badge that says transcriptomics and you
can click on that i'll go ahead and open
it as a new tab because we'll go to that
in a moment
but this will open your syllabus your
access to all of the information that
the program is intended to guide you
through etc
you can also find your program under the
programs tab over here
if you click on this
you should see access to biomed vulcan
single cell transcriptomics
down here
now once you get into this and you start
taking some of the asynchronous courses
the courses that you have started or
have you taken even if it's only partial
like a portion of a first lesson
it will then show up under the courses
tab so you'll be able to go to this and
quickly access any of the courses that
you're currently working on
such as see i've completed python course
one uh introduction to bioinformatics
and i'm mostly done with the bio ml
course so if you're curious about how to
find a course that's already started you
can go here
you will also once you complete a course
receive a certificate
and this will be similar to the
certificate you'll receive once you
complete the entirety of the program
it'll look something similar to this so
if you're an outside individual
individual it'll look very similar to
this it'll say that you've completed the
program
and it'll be signed by an individual
from pine biotech or the omixlogic team
but like i said if you're from lsu or
lbrn it will look slightly different
where it'll be customized for your
institution and it will be signed by a
different individual from that
institution
now
what now what i want to show you really
quickly is the syllabus so if you click
on this particular link it'll open a
page that looks like this if you don't
if you're not enrolled in this
particular program it will look a little
different your name will not pop up here
so if that doesn't happen and you know
you're supposed to be enrolled please
contact one of us
however if you are enrolled it'll look
like this it'll show your point system
your name etc
and you can scroll down here to find the
syllabus
now
once you complete the lecture and all of
the information associated here these
online resources
you'll be able to click on complete
session and as you go through you'll see
that each week a different session will
become available for you to complete
once you've completed all of the
sessions which will go through december
for this particular training module
you'll be able to complete all of the
sessions and you'll receive your
certificate
each one of these
lectures is associated with a live
lecture which will be recorded if you're
not able to get to that as well as these
associated online resources which you
can click on and it'll take you to
additional learning information that you
should go through for each particular
lecture
um i will address what's the difference
between the course from uh i believe you
mean lsu um so there's no actual
difference between the content between
lsu lbrn or outside individuals it just
has to do with how you're going about
registering and how you have to find the
program
so that being said i'm going to go ahead
and stop sharing and i'm going to hand
off
the lecture to ilia at amelia bronski
the ceo of pine biotin
thank you elaine
and welcome everyone thank you for
joining today i think that we will try
to address all of your questions here in
just a second
i do ask that you just kind of hold on
to all of the questions until the end of
the session where i will just stop and
kind of read them through
in the meantime let me start sharing my
screen
all right so welcome everyone uh again
this program is going or this
orientation session is going to give you
a lot more clarity and detail about
what we're actually going to cover in
the program
and how the program is going to result
in practical skills that you can use
potentially for your research project
or to just know about how to analyze
transcriptomic or rna-seq data
so
let's start by just kind of giving you a
broad overview like lane already
mentioned
the data processing part including some
of the popular tools that you probably
are familiar with like
bow tie
high sat hd seek
all kinds of pre-processing methods
including methods of
data quality all of that will be covered
in the beginning we will then go on to
talk about
gene and isoform expression so how can
we identify novel isoforms how can we
analyze differences in changing
expression how can we find complex
patterns of gene expression and how can
we prepare them for different types of
analyses that you have to understand a
little bit in detail to make sure that
you're selecting the right type of
analysis and the right types of
preparation steps for that analysis
then we'll talk about statistics and
we'll briefly touch on the most popular
application of rna-seq data specifically
bulk rnac data for differential gene
expression typically that means you have
a condition and a control how do you
find which genes could explain the
differences between the condition and
the control
and then we will also talk about data
mining and machine learning and we'll
talk talk both in the context of bulk
and are in single cell rnac data so
we'll discuss
how some of the traditional methods
kind of provide us with limited
flexibility and then how these methods
could be expanded and how can we learn
from different types of machine learning
tools about the biological phenomena
that we are studying with this kind of
data
so before we begin talking about this i
do want to explain why rna-seq
i assume most of you are already
familiar with this but i'll just briefly
touch on this and
specifically mention
that
rna-seq is
number one an excellent proxy for
protein expression
so proteins define the phenotype if you
think about a skin cell as opposed to a
let's say liver cell
how can we define the difference the
difference is in their activity and that
activity is defined by whatever proteins
are being produced
and that's kind of the the most obvious
the major part of that difference
however
all kinds of additional steps between
genes that are encoded in the dna the
regulation of those genes
and then the mature
mrna that we're actually sequencing
typically
those all fall under the domain of
transcriptomics and we can apply
transcriptomic data analysis to find
many different types of signals by
understanding what is the data
representing and so we will talk a
little bit about different ways to
actually extract rna
prepare libraries for sequencing and
then different strategies of sequencing
which all result in some considerations
that you will have in mind when you're
processing and preparing your data for
analysis
the other thing that i want to address
is that
uh rna-seq or high-throughput
transcriptomic data has been
kind of a way to
expand the dynamic range so-called
dynamic range of high throughput
sequencing compared to other methods so
there are other methods of
quantification of rna or mrna expression
[Music]
there's pcr there's microarrays
and we will focus on rna-seq to kind of
look into that data but we will also
keep in mind that a lot of the
validation could be still done with
these other methods and so a lot of you
probably are more familiar with those
methods we're not trying to replace
those methods we're trying to expand the
depth and the
kind of variability of the data
so that we can extract more from a
single experiment so we will talk about
that a little bit and so finally the
applications of rna-seq
there are many different types of
applications of rna-seq
in most cases these applications have to
do with
integration of omix data so if you think
about comparing condition and control
you have a simple
metadata these samples are
representative of this condition this
these samples are represented of these
conditions
in the modern kind of experimentation
strategy a lot of the data comes from
sources with a lot of variation so we
will talk about data sets that come with
clinical data that clinical data has a
lot of variation a lot of variables and
factors they need to consider
we'll talk about different collections
that might include sequencing of cell
lines might include different types of
animal models of human disease so all of
these factors are going to be somehow
represented in the data that we analyze
and so a lot of the focus of this
program and the reason why we're not
just going to stop at the differential
gene expression stage is because all of
these factors
generate complex data complex patterns
and to identify patterns that are
different
from noise we have to
kind of rely on these more advanced
tools
in the context of the program we will
actually take a look at several
different types of applications of
rna-seq
that primarily are biomedical so again
this is
primarily for those that are interested
in biomedical applications
and we will look at
different methods of diagnostics and
cancer biology disease classification
and patient stratification and we'll
talk about single cell and tissue
composition which is a very popular
technique but is typically applied in
very specific uh kind of applications or
domains like immunology for example so
we'll talk a little bit about how those
examples can help us understand the
methods and can help us
apply them in a meaningful way
so today what i want to do is briefly
give you a glimpse of each one of these
different topics that you see on the
screen so i will talk about the tools
and resources for transcriptomics data
analysis lane already mentioned that we
will be talking about the platform the t
binomial platform i'll show you a little
bit what that looks like we'll talk
about what processing means as compared
to analysis and then kind of how
different sections fit together
including some of the tools that are
beyond the platform so some of the
limitations of these uh gui or visual
user-friendly tools are that they
provide you with some standard methods
and to go beyond those standard methods
you know you have to know a little bit
of coding so we'll talk a little bit
about r and python coding that could be
very useful for anyone who will like to
deal with this kind of data
we will also talk about specifically
what is the difference between bulk and
single cell rna-seq data and what kinds
of methods we will cover in the single
cell rna-seq analysis section and then
we'll also talk a little bit about the
different types of project examples that
we have prepared
these will be essentially curated data
sets that we will utilize for the
different tutorials
so as lane already mentioned you can
take a look at the program page the
program page will give you a good
overview of all of the topics that are
covered and we'll provide you with some
links where you can take this
asynchronous course material that
essentially you can complete on your own
time frame and the access will be
available from october
all the way until the end of december
at the end of december we will evaluate
everybody's
profiles and see how many points you
have and what courses you have completed
and what certificates you have and based
on that evaluation at the end you will
be offered a certificate now there's
going to be a special category of
certificates that have to do with an
independent project so if you are
interested in developing an independent
project during this time you can reach
out to one of us but you can also just
see that under your profile and so on
this program page another important
thing that i would like to show you
okay so on
this page
you will be able to see if you scroll
down so here you have for each one of
these sessions you have the associated
resources
here you have just a collection of these
resources that you can just scroll
through and see what's included
and here at the bottom what's important
is that you also have access to our team
so if you have a question if you want to
ask a question just click on that button
if you're already logged in of course it
will redirect you to our slack channel
we have a dedicated slack channel for
this particular program
okay so if you're already registered you
should be added to this if you're not if
you are registered for the program and
you haven't been added to this slack
channel then make sure that you click on
that button and then you will be
redirected to this channel now here is
where you can ask us any questions you
can ask about difficulties that you're
facing with one of the things that we're
trying to do you can also request a
meeting with one of us if you're stuck
and you feel like you need additional
attention and help so we're always happy
to jump on a call explain something that
you might not understand or work through
some of the technical challenges that
you might have
okay so
again most of the methods that we are
going to be discussing are going to be
available on the tbi info platform and
in parallel you will be able to see how
those methods are coded in a language in
a coding language like r or python we
will also introduce you to some of the
online repositories and tools that are
going to be very useful as you're
conducting
transcriptomic data analysis and
interpretation and you will have to rely
on to really make sure that you're
finding something that could be
validated and you are
essentially uh producing high quality
results
so let's briefly talk about the tbr
platform the tbi info platform is an
environment that packages all kinds of
executables behind a user interface so
what does that look like if you will
go with me
to server.tbio.info
i want to briefly show you
what we're going to be doing
okay so please let me know once you're
on this link
and maybe you can let me know by putting
number one or yes or something like that
in the chat and i will just give it a
moment so that everybody can
take their time and get there
okay so let me know once you're on this
portal
server.tbioinfo the link is in the chat
in case thank you
okay so
once you're registered for the program
you will have access and there are
several different levels of access that
you can get the first is a demo access
and i'll just briefly show you what the
demo access means
this is to help build the logic of
analysis so when i say the logic of
analysis what i mean is for you to
understand how do the different pieces
connect together it's not very obvious
why there are so many tools out there
that essentially do the same thing right
so if you think about mapping mapping
could be done with star with bow tie
with top hat with hisat all of these
different methods so one of the
important objectives here is to
categorize these different tools
according to what their function is for
example you can he you can see here
after we click the start button you will
see down here an example pipeline that
we're just going to build here
you will see that the first step that is
highlighted here is pre-processing so we
want to get
fast qc for example quality of our
original reads we want to take a look at
what is the difference between adapters
and the actual reads that are being
produced by the sequencer we will talk
about pcr amplification how do we adjust
for the bias of pcr
then we will be introduced to different
methods of mapping and the mapping could
happen based on alignment to the full
genome or alignment to only the
expressed part of the genome or the
transcripts and genes that are recorded
in the gtf file so we'll talk about some
of the differences there
we'll then look at ways to construct
isoforms so obviously genes is what we
are we a lot of times want to quantify
but those genes are comprised of several
different transcripts
in many cases these transcripts are
actually key to understanding the
disease and the dysregulation that we
observe in diseases like cancer so we'll
talk about how
that is
found in the raw data how is that added
then to the gtf file and then what are
the steps that we need to take to
actually quantify and what are some of
the different tools that are available
for quantification so as you can see
each button here represents a different
algorithm a different set of methods
and some of the configurations of those
methods are going to be described and
they're evident in the names of these uh
different buttons that you see right
here
so that will be our first kind of
experience and i'm just briefly showing
you this as an example so that you
understand why this is an important part
for someone starting to learn about rna
sequencing for those of you that are
already familiar with this step
what you will be able to do is compare
different methods and understand the
differences so that you can be more
informed about why certain methods apply
to different situations when you're
looking for differences in gene
expression when you're looking for novel
isoforms when you're looking
specifically at variation at the exon
level etc so many different questions
could be addressed if your pipeline is
designed correctly there's also a
computational load so
having the right parameters and having
the right kind of pipelines designed if
you want a quick answer or a more
in-depth question is also going to be
addressed right here
okay uh the other thing that we will
talk about after this is the actual
objective of the analysis so once you
build this pipeline
you will see that each method is going
to be explained if you are interested
you can learn more about the inputs the
outputs the settings and the idea behind
the algorithm and then we will focus on
the output so how do we
turn this information turn this data
into biologically interpretable
interpretable information so what do
these methods actually produce they
produce tables they produce numbers how
do we turn those numbers into something
that we can interpret from a biological
standpoint so we will talk about going
from tables of expression
to statistical analysis to annotation
and then enrichment analysis so we will
cover that kind of basic process of
extracting biological pathways that
include metabolic and signaling pathways
that then you can understand in the
context of statistical properties that
were produced as a result of that
analysis
for example dec 2 and gene set
enrichment analysis
now at the same time we will also see
how transcriptomic data might include
additional
information
that is going to be important for use
cases right so the use cases are going
to be cancer neurodegenerative diseases
infectious diseases and even agriculture
and biotechnology so we will look at
several of these examples to see how the
same type of data could be used in
several different ways and we will learn
about some of the typical outputs how do
people produce figures that then are
used in publications to show what was
the actual result what are the
parameters that are typically used and
why those parameters are used in
different situations
now we will also talk about another
challenge so as i mentioned in the
beginning this standard control versus
condition or one condition versus
another condition oftentimes is now
replaced by
complex variation where you have
multiple conditions and in those
conditions you want to find patterns of
gene expression that could be
informative and that means that you can
select biomarkers or signature
patterns and start to interpret them
either by use case how do you actually
utilize this information or through a
more mechanistic traditional biological
interpretation or what does this gene do
now here we will talk about different
strategies for normalization which is
important for statistical analysis as
well as machine learning we will talk
about transformation of the data we will
talk about data mining and
classification now yesterday we had an
orientation session dedicated to the
data science program so this program and
the data science program will cover some
of the same methods
there the focus is much more on coding
and being able to understand the math
and the statistics behind some of these
methods here we're primarily going to
use it as a way to try and apply these
methods to rna-seq data and see what
comes out right what is the use case for
these different methods
one important part that we will talk
about is
exploratory analysis and biological
signals so we'll talk about how do we
use some of these methods to understand
where's the signal and where's the noise
or what is the association between
different features
and annotation of those features so
metadata that we have about these
features how do we find some
associations that we can then turn into
a hypothesis so this is called
hypothesis generating so a lot of times
you might not know
let's say what is the difference between
breast cancer and liver cancer so can i
find out i can take some data try to
compare some of those samples and then
see if there's a big difference a lot of
genes or a small difference or maybe
some variation at an additional level
like
the sex or age of the patients right so
that exploratory analysis can give you a
hypothesis that you can then turn into a
hypothesis that could be tested using
statistical methods
now a lot of the downstream analysis
methods
have um standard settings
that people use
but they could produce many different
results so oftentimes you will see that
people would like to have heat maps and
volcano plots and different types of
subsets of data for the publication so
we'll talk a little bit more about how
these downstream methods of analysis
could be coded in r or python and we
have some exercises prepared that you
can complete independently to make sure
that you understand the syntax of the
code you can run this method
independently and then you can produce
the right kinds of visual outputs that
would be useful for a publication for
example
so in that context
as lane already mentioned
we have this playground this coding
playground and i would like to just
briefly show you what that looks like
okay so again here if you're on the
program page
if you go to this course
you will find that each course has a tag
so in the beginning all of the tags are
learned or the logic behind the analysis
if you click on load more you will see
that down below you will start getting
lessons in r and python
and so some of the basic steps for this
analysis for example in r are going to
be explained in a step-by-step fashion
so you will go from the very basics of
installing r
to then working with rnac data
understanding your data frame or the
table of gene expression
and then learning the syntax of the code
in whatever language you're going to be
coding this to actually transform and
prepare the data for analysis now once
you get into that stage in the beginning
you just want to try and make sure that
this code works so some of the initial
assignments are going to be just basic
just take what we did and run it
now after that you will get into a
little bit more complex assignments that
will include
manipulation of the code so how to
change the code so that you can get
something that you're actually looking
for
and so that is going to be just so that
you can develop a library or pieces of
code that you could reuse for different
applications and this could all be done
in the browser you can also take this
to your computer so if you have your own
setup where you have rstudio for example
you've got your data you can work
directly from our studio with the exact
same code
or in python you can use some of the
other
developer environments
that you can run the data there so we
will go over that as well
an important part of this would be to
know how to use some of these
environments so here you can see the r
studio environment and one of the
exercises performing differential gene
expression and all the way to creating a
heat map table at the end
including many different coding enviro
examples that you will practice
independently how to load data how to
do descriptive statistics and
visualization dimensionality reduction
differential gene expression et cetera
so all of these will be important parts
of uh what we will cover
now let's talk a little bit more about
single cell rna-seq data
single cell rna-seq data is a novel
approach to understand gene expression
at the individual cell level now
individual cell level
means that if you imagine kind of a
hospital right and you want to
understand what is the average
temperature of a sick patient in the
hospital that's a very
difficult question to answer if all you
can measure is just the average across
hundreds or thousands of individuals and
the same thing with cells typically
some steps could be done at the
biological side for example you can
separate your cells into different types
you can maybe take cells and grow them
in a very kind of homogeneous
environment
but in any case a lot of the conditions
that we're interested to understand like
cancer like different immunological
conditions they have to do with
variability
and to understand this variability
several different methods have been
developed as you can see right here
starting from about 2009 and all the way
to the present day where
single cell transcriptomics is becoming
a major focus for a lot of different
studies
so first of all we will talk about the
differences in preparing that
transcriptomic data for analysis so it's
going to be very different from your
standard kind of
mapping and quantification a lot of this
has to do with barcoding of individual
cells a lot of it has to do with making
sure that those cells
are denoised the data is denoised and
some of the
lacking data is imputed so you do have
zero inflated data the data sets are
much larger and to address a lot of
these things there are specific steps
that have to be done
in the processing of those
of that data
and then we will talk about three main
applications of downstream analysis of
single cell rna-seq
clustering so clustering by cell type
for example typically using marker genes
so we will talk about the requirements
for single cell rna-seq where you do
have to a lot of times either find
somebody else's list of marker genes or
maybe even find those marker genes
yourself and some of the considerations
around
for example flows phytometry based and
gene expression based markers
then
differential expression right so if i do
find clusters and those clusters have a
meaningful separation how can i find the
genes that are differentially expressed
between
these different cell types or cell types
that are also in a different state and
that's when we will get to this idea of
pseudotime where we typically think of
cells that differentiate like for
example immune cells that differentiate
over time
or cells
that become from
you know undifferentiated state to a
differentiated state so we will talk
about this pseudo time idea and how that
could be used to differentiate between
different types of cells in our data
one of the important packages that we
will talk about is the serrat package
this package allows us to do a lot of
these initial stages denoise the data
make an object that then we can work
with within that object to start looking
at these different clusters using t-sne
or u-map and then using the markers
identifying the characteristics of these
markers and then looking at
how
we can
kind of you know make sense of this data
how can we count how many cells have a
particular gene at a certain level of
expression underexpressed overexpressed
etc how can we use this in the context
of different studies like immunology and
others
and the other two packages that we will
cover is monocle and tc scan
these two packages allow us to look at
these pseudo-time trajectories and based
on these trajectories
i'm sorry to
interpret the gene expression data and
the clustering data that we have from
the initial steps
so finally we will use some of the
methods that we have learned
through the program to apply them to
exemplar projects and one of the main
idea behind the way that these projects
were selected was to organize them by
their level of systems complexity so
here you can see cell lines to xenograph
models or kind of human model or animal
models of human disease to real data
coming from patients for example so in
that context right we are going to
discuss also some of the experimentation
strategies
where we have
either more or less control over the
data how it was generated to be able to
use appropriate methods to account for
that complexity and to remember the
limitations of the type of data that
we're using to make generalizable
interpretations so
we'll talk about projects like the
evolution of breast cancer
classification or how multi-omics data
transcriptomic data and other types of
omics data have changed the way that a
disease is categorized or classified
and what does that mean for these
diseases in terms of treatment and
diagnostics
we will also
take exampler publications and kind of
break them down to understand how the
data was generated what the analysis
was and how was that interpreted and
used
by the authors and we have several other
examples
including several different projects on
immunology
oncology biotechnology
and even agriculture so we do have
several different examples that you can
work through and those are called
projects so you will find there on the
portal how you can go between courses
and projects and the courses kind of
talk about the methods and then the
projects introduce you to what is the
research question what is the data set
and how would you approach addressing or
answering that question with
data analysis methods
so to summarize um
these kinds of methods that we will
learn and the experience that you will
get from these courses are is going to
prepare you to not only
read papers and understand how
these visuals that you see
in papers were produced
but also technically to understand how
to connect the different steps of
analysis with the intended outcome so
when you have that figure in mind or you
have that question in mind what are the
steps to go from raw data to process
data to hypothesis testing or to other
methods of analysis and annotation
we will also talk about how to try and
apply the same methods to novel data
sets and here you can either find
many different rna-seq or transcriptomic
data sets online
on public repositories like ncbi
or
how to apply it to a data set of your
own so again for those of you that are
from lsu and lvrn if you are
participating in the lbrn research
program or the lsu if you're working in
some kind of lab and you have some of
that data you will be able to upload
that data to the platform and start
analyzing it or if you already have
process data you will learn how to
analyze the downstream part of the
analysis either on your computer
or
we will show you some other environments
where you can do it online or on the
cloud
so to kind of see some of the data sets
uh i want to briefly go to
ncbi so ncbi i'm sure that most of you
are familiar with it
if you just search for the term
transcriptomics
on ncbi
you will see the amount of data that is
available
specifically for transcriptomics right
so
geo data sets are data sets that
typically have been already processed so
these are tables of expression you can
see that close to 5 000 data sets and
for the raw data so you can see under
bio projects we have over 5 000 bio
projects those include multiple types of
uh or multiple samples per project and
so you can see the sequence read archive
over
close to 73 000 of those so there's
really a lot to choose from right if you
are thinking of using this program to
develop an independent project
this is the way that you can do that you
can
go into
if if you go into this section you will
be able to find a lot of interesting
data sets
and one of the things that we will learn
in this program is how to understand the
different terms that people use when
they submit the data to ncbi
so that you can use that metadata to
find a data set that you might be
interested in
so uh you know just looking at some of
these examples
you can see single cell transcriptomics
is becoming one of this you know
important terms that comes up a lot
you can see also a lot of other types of
transcriptomic data and importantly take
a look at how many samples we are
talking about right so if previously
your typical rna-seq experiment was
maybe
you know tens or maybe even three to
five samples per condition and maybe
tens of samples per condition you can
see that thousands of samples
is now becoming somewhat standard and so
a major limitation to work with such
data is just simply the computational
power that you have access to on your
laptop or your computer
and that is a major component of this
program is to introduce you to some of
these
big data analysis tools that allow you
to process
analyze and interpret these huge data
sets that obviously it's impossible to
do with this traditional method of just
statistical analysis between
well-defined control groups you really
have to rely on an understanding of the
process or the analysis stages and steps
and then implement it in some kind of a
high performance compute performance
computing environment and that is the
major objective of this program
not only to explain what rna-seq is and
how it's used but also to provide you
with this hands-on ability to analyze
data
and do it all in about three months
okay so uh to summarize um
what we
will talk about in this program
is
a series of
use cases that essentially introduce
methods of analysis
types of data and ability to work with
that data all the way from raw to
processed to interpretable biologically
and and then potentially use that for
your own project
and
just kind of give you a summary uh of
what we cover today and what this
program will offer you is you will be
able to learn rna-seq data processing
analysis and interpretation
leverage cloud-based tools for hands-on
assignments and for big data
apply machine learning to large
biomedical data sets
complete and present an independent
research project if you join this
program for the whole three months
that's plenty of time
and obtain a certificate of excellence
and recognition so either a certificate
of completion as lane already mentioned
it could be signed by someone from lbrn
or your institution or directly on the
portal you will also get an automated
certificate signed by one of our teams
so finally i just want to show you where
all of this information is going to be
found so as lane already mentioned and
if you even during this session created
your profile on learn
there are several different ways that
you can access all of this information
if you want this guided experience with
a certificate and everything else
there's the program if you're not ready
for the program and you just want to
understand and explore some of the
resources you can do that as well so you
can go to the courses and just with a
basic subscription
you can get access to a lot of the
materials that we discussed this program
specifically is going to organize those
materials into something that will
lead from one thing to the next and
organized in a logical way you will get
videos released to you on the dates that
are specified
and again for those of you that want to
understand a lot more about this program
this is the the page if you have not
really seen this page in detail i
recommend that you do
uh so
on this page you will find a brief
overview of the program you will also
find here
the different uh sessions that are
planned
and those sessions have the associated
resources which are lessons from
asynchronous courses and will come with
videos that you can watch
that kind of explain how these different
resources are connected together
finally for those of you that have not
completed your registration
if you are from lsu or lbrn you can
confirm your registration using this
ilab registration link now after today's
session we will be following up with an
email that has a video on how to
register through ilab that's
specifically for lsu or albaron members
if you're not and you have registered to
the webinar session we have your
information and we will be emailing you
the steps to complete registration on
the program page very simple create a
profile go to the program page you find
the different options the different
levels that you would like to pursue and
then you complete your registration
right there on the portal
at the end you will receive a
certificate for those of you that are
from lsu and lbrm this will be a printed
certificate so it will be a paper
certificate presented to you by lbrn
and lbrn stands for louisiana biomedical
research network or by your institution
here you have some examples of things
that we will cover
and here you can also find some of the
slides that you probably saw in today's
session
just as a reminder and some of the
feedback that we received from previous
participants
as you will see that majority of the
people who participated in this program
previously are graduate students and
faculty so we are expecting that most of
you that are joining this program this
semester are already familiar with some
of the basics that we discussed
in part today
but if you are an undergraduate student
and you would still like to participate
we just need to evaluate your
understanding of some of the basic
terminology and then we could direct you
to some supplementary materials that
will introduce the key topics and skills
that you would need to take the full
course so if you have questions about
that or anything else i will be ready to
answer those now thank you
so again if you have any questions
do let me know
and i can answer them now
okay and someone was asking about the
recording of this session so we will
send an email with the recording of the
session
and we also have a youtube link that you
can navigate to and find all of this
information
there
and
yeah so is this program totally online
yes
um
if you're a beginner which course is
useful for a beginner um
so uh the uh beginner courses we have a
full program in this uh semester called
introduction to bioinformatics
and i would recommend you take a look at
that one
um so this is
the same kind of a program that we just
discussed here but for beginner level
uh as you can see
uh there's going to be a little bit more
of a focus on the basic terminology and
kind of some introductory materials to
understand what bioinformatics is how
it's applied to different types of next
generation sequencing data so that's one
option to do that
another option to do that is really we
have a course that you can take i
believe for free
called bytes and molecules okay so
this course right here called bytes and
molecules
anyone after you have registered on the
portal can take it
as you can see right here
and make sure that you scroll all the
way to the bottom and you click on load
more
it has everything you need to know to
kind of get started right so from
understanding kind of the relationship
between biology and data to citizen
science
how this data is actually encoded in the
dna how does it get translated to
proteins and what are protein structures
and then introduction to genomics
transcriptomics and metagenomics as well
as some introduction to coding and
applications of bioinformatics like
precision medicine or even space omnics
and astronaut health
how do you get into this beginners
course so again you can either go
through a program which is a whole
semester-long one cr equivalent of a one
credit course that's called introduction
to bioinformatics and just gave the link
here in the chat
if you just want to try and kind of
understand what is all this about you
can take this course uh directly
for microarray data analysis there's
some mention of microarrays uh in the
transformations course as well um you
know some of the methods of analysis are
very similar to what we use for bulk
rna-seq so if you just join the
transcriptomics course you can find that
there
what is the difference between the
training course and the research program
so in addition to yeah so first of all
every course here right if i just
complete all of these courses
i will you will get a certificate of
completion that will be just an
automated certificate that will be
generated you can you know download it
share it etc
the training program is a program that
was verified according to academic
standards including equivalent of credit
hours or contact hours
and
objectives of that level of training so
it's a more
kind of
rigorous approach to evaluating the
criteria of training and the outcomes
it's a training module it's not a an
accredited course it's a training module
because it is offered by the louisiana
biomedical research network and as a
part of the graduate certificate
training through biomed which is a core
facility
is this course available yearly and will
it always be online
yeah so physical lectures maybe in the
future after the pandemic gets all
sorted out we might have physical
lectures i mean right now these uh could
be done asynchronously we have some
other courses that are
um
that are online through zoom sessions
like this one
how much do you need to pay to get
certificates upon completion of courses
so just ten dollars a month is the
starting
point so if you just want to navigate
different courses and kind of complete
them independently there's a basic
subscription that you can opt for
in this program this particular program
so every program has a price it's a
negotiated price with the university so
that certificate
will be according to you participating
in that program
um
okay for physical training we we've had
previously physical training at lsu
which is baton rouge louisiana and other
places if you are in india we have
several universities that are offering
these kinds of courses there we have
some in nigeria as well so they're in
israel so we have several different
locations where this kind of training is
offered
okay so i hope that okay so i want to
mention one thing about the research
program
so probably a lot of you that have been
seeing what we do
have seen the research fellowship
program
the research fellowship program is a
separate type of a program after you
have completed the basic training
if you want to work with a mentor and
complete an independent research project
you can have
that through
our research fellowship program just
show you what that means
so here under your profile again you
have courses you have programs which is
this is a program or you have uh
projects and so these
projects are independent projects
essentially they follow the same steps
that you would take if you were to write
a publication
or
you know a submission to a conference
for a poster presentation so all we
essentially have mentors that guide you
on how to find a data set uh develop a
an analysis plan bioinformatics analysis
plan and then perform all the analysis
with the final results and then
how to submit it on this portal so that
it's ready if you would like to take it
to a poster or a publication later on
okay do we have a training center in
nigeria we do
um
lo me if you could uh share
your email with marketing at pine bio
so if you have any questions about how
to contact different uh training centers
you can uh go to marketing
at
pine.file
that's the email address so just email
them and they will direct you to the
right person
is there any course which has one-to-one
trainer for any particular course so a
lot of the research fellowship that we
offer is
groups these are group sessions but you
do have access to a trainer or a mentor
and you can request a one-on-one meeting
including in this program as well if you
are a part of the program you have
access to the slack channel on the slack
channel you will be connected to all the
mentors and you can request a one-on-one
meeting if you don't understand
something or have questions
okay if you have any uh technical issues
uh along the way
we do have a support team as well
support at pine.bio you can reach out to
them with any issues that you might have
about running your pipelines you know
getting stuck with code
and other technical issues as well if
you don't have access to something or
something like that
okay so thank you everyone for joining
if you do have any other questions
please do reach out to us marketing in
pine bio for any questions regarding
registration payments and how to get
into the program supported pine bio if
you have any kinds of technical
questions so your pipeline's not working
your account's not opening up you don't
see what you're supposed to see right
supported pine bio if you have any
questions about the curriculum or how to
use these resources for your
university students or groups of
researchers
please do reach out to me i'd be happy
to walk you through how other
universities are using this and how you
can use this as well and i am hoping to
see all of you join this program
if this is the right fit again remember
that this is primarily for graduate and
research oriented students or faculty if
you have another level we have other
programs that you can look into and
we're always happy to find ways to make
it work for you so if something doesn't
work out financially or technically or
time-wise please do reach out to us we
have a number of options for you to get
access in any case
thank you and
we will stop
this webinar for now and again we do
have a recorded version of this webinar
that we will send out after this fight